je vais vous dire que en voyant cette
vidéo j'ai été choquée j'ai vu à la fois
une scène d'affrontements violents et
poursuite entre manifestants et forces
de l'ordre très confuse je vous prie
d'imaginer les conditions dans laquelle
je les ai vus en nouvelle calédonie mais
une scène d'intervention d'une personne
qui est manifestement monsieur benalla
et qui à l'évidence a agi en dehors de
ses fonctions à la présidence de la
république
j'ai alors souhaité appeler monsieur
benalla immédiatement le premier contact
téléphonique que j'ai eue avec lui
c'était juste après ce premier contact
avec patrick strzoda
ce même soir gelé fermement sermonnait
je lui ai indiqué il a reconnu cours de
cette conversation sa présence sur les
lieux de la manifestation
il a été très clair sur le fait et vous
y reviendrez qu'il ne m'a pas sollicité
- chef de cabinet pour être sur ces
lieux là mais je n'étais pas là il a
donc sollicité le directeur de cabinet
il a justifié et je tiens à le dire son
comportement par sa volonté d'aider les
policiers pris à partie par des
manifestants mais des manifestants
violents qui avaient je le cite de
mémoire me dit il jeté des projectiles
sur les forces de l'ordre
je lui indique immédiatement il le sait
parce que les choses se font de manière
concurrente qu'une sanction a été prise
et
et lui est notifiée mon avis sur ce qui
s'est passé le 1er mai et qu'il s'agit
est là aussi j insiste fortement sur ce
point d'un comportement individuel
fautif d'un comportement individuel
fautif qui pour moi est clairement
distinct de la mission du service que
j'ai exposé je rappelle évidemment
qu'une information judiciaire est
ouverte sur ce cas d'espèce je veux
rappeler également fortement qu'une
sanction administrative a été prise
immédiatement et j'en ai rappelé la
chronologie
il appartient désormais à la justice de
notre pays d'établir les responsabilités
des individus poursuivis pour ma part
dans le cadre de cette commission
denquête j'ai la volonté de répondre
précisément est complètement à toutes
vos questions dans le respect des
principes énoncés et avec la plus grande
transparence
le président de la république m'a
autorisé à venir devant vous ce faisant
il souhaite contribuer oui j'ai bien dit
autoriser ce faisant il souhaite
contribuer à la manifestation de la
vérité chers collègues seul monsieur
loches la parole je vous prie de
m'excuser m'a néanmoins demandé de
rappeler le cadre juridique dans lequel
s'inscrit cette audition je dois veiller
je sais que vous y êtes attachés au
principe de séparation des pouvoirs qui
ne me permettra pas de répondre aux
questions portant sur des faits donnant
lieu à une information judiciaire et à
celles portant sur l'organisation
interne présidence de république et je